Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now we have a number of uninvited guest on our sub,
*inhale* but we've got another problem.
There's the active lava zone yet to explore
and we are not near it...
(sea dragon) *roAAAAR*
and big boy over there seems to be pretty peeved that I left our fight
mid... fight
and so I'm just going to have to come back eventually
and beat the shit out of him just a little bit more than I already have.
But I'm lost.
Where am I right now?
Why can't I see anything in front of me?
Ahhhh hey..
Hidy, hidy, hidy, hoe, neighbor.
I'm gonna go somewhere else because
FRICK YOU I'm gonna go find me an inac- i mean active lava zone.
So the active lava zone is somewhere down in a crevice.
Deep in the... bosom of the world.
Maybe even this one.
In fact it looks like it's definitely this one.
This seems like a crevice type crevice... filled with lava plumes... of some sort.
I was apparently right next to it.
*unsure markimoo sounds*
hedehedeheded hoe
This looks scary as FUUUUUUUgggddde.
oooh bananza mo manza
is this where im supposed to be?
i see a little bit of HOLE there, but i don't know if i will be able to fit though
Mr. Fister would but something tells me that I don't want to take Mr. Fister out on my own just to go into that hole.
*unsure mark*
OK HERE WE GOOOOOOO I SHOULDN'T TAKE THIS DOWN THERE
you know what I'm not gonna do that I-I'm gonna
I'm gonna go against my better judgement
and I'm going to go down in this hole
by myself
can I repair you from here
do you need repairing I can't even remember
but I bet the depth thing is broken again
so I gotta pop that back out put that back in
xo (haha EXO) depth warning
I know because your stupid
YOU'RE STUPID
alright fine I'm gonna save and then I'll compound prepared as best I can.
donno if its gonna work but its all the best I got
FOBIDOSHKI
AAAHHH CRUSH DEPTH I KNOW
where are you where are you where did you go
oh hey! There you are. COME HERE gimme you
pop that bad boy out pop that bad boy in
thats all it takes
hop in... wait whats the... whats the repair at right now?
no... no such luck?
AAAH?
*gibberish* indestructible is it?
oh ok its full
alrighty then... byyyyye
good bye big box barry
I'll remember you in the... terrifying darkness
god... the last time I was here
was long before any of this was ever finished
nothing in here was textured besides the most basic lava.
DOOO MAA GAD!!!
that ain't good.
I have no food... I have no water...
why am i  gonna go down here? because I'm an idiot that's why
do I have water? NOPE I don't.
I should go make water imma go make water real quick, I'll be back
a ha... problem
I have no salt
I can't make WATER without SALT
ok this is officially gonna suck
imma try this... because... uuuuuuuuuuuhhhhh...
I think we can fit. I'm pretty sure we can fit down here
I think we can fit yea.
oh yeah... you're good... you're good.... you're good... you're good... you're good you're good you're good
AAAAAAAANNNNNDDDDDDSSS
YYYAAAAAAND made it
ok i made it
I think we are a little tilted but I think we made it.
hello?
hi underwater creatures :D
OOOOOH thats what they mean by active
HEEEY
How you doing there buddy?
hey you still bein' an asshole?
great you keep doin' that over there
and I'll be over here buildin' my base right in your face
and then imma gonna fuck you up ALL OVER THE PLACE!
he seems very pissed about that challenge
and I don't know if hes gonna come after waaaaoooh I see it oh your guarding it aren't 'cha?
oh you're guarding it
I'm just about at the limit of my cyclops
bit I'm still gonna come down here and FUCK YOUR SHIT UUUHUUHUPPP!!!
you wanna ram?.. HUH?!
I'LL MESS YOU UP
BUDDY HAA YEAAHH
don't come near me
hey I'm scared
but that doesn't mean that I'm not dangerous
Just because you can kick my ass in an instant, doesn't mean that you should.
Hey, take the moral high ground you big... bitch baby!
Alright, fine then...
He ain't bothering nobody but for some reason
it's a lot more clear down here than it was up there.
Oh boy...
Okay then
Loading!
Alright, there we go.
Well, there it is.
That's the thing.
That is legitimately the thing.
Now... You can't go in it yet.
And that's the big tragedy of it all. You can't go in this thing.
But it's all here. It exists.
And it has some sort of front door there but I-I still don't think you can go in that thing. Can you?
Can you?!?
No, no no no no.
You wouldn't be able to go in there, would you?
Nahh, nah. Maybe in that front alcove area.
I'm gonna take Mr. Fister out and see what's whaaaat over here.
But, I'm pretty sure. I'm pretty sure it ain't no kind of nothing.
Okay, yeah... So it's here. But you can't go in it.
There's no console to put in the big glowing blue artifact here.
As much as I want to, there's just no way to get in there at the moment so
I'm just gonna have to make-do and ahh *dung*
What the hell was that? What the hell is any of this anyway?
What are these floating little boxes here?
Its just really quiet down here.
It's just- That's what makes it really disturbing.
Hey, you!
Come here you!
I want a bit of you!
Lava eye eye? Cool.
Lavarang?
Yeesh, abababbababa gimme gimme gimme
Gimme, gimme , gimme. Yayoyoy.
Lava Boomerang, I know I'm dying right now but you don't need to worry about that.
I'm fine.
Lava boomerang. I'm-I'm hoping I can get some water out of this.
*moans in the distance*
Yeesh
Well that guy's gonna be a noisy neighbour keeping me up at night.
You may be asking yourself: ''Why Markiplier, why would you make a base down here?''
I say to that: ''Why not?''
Usually my answer to pretty much any question directed towards ME... when it questions my capability as a leader!
and a Pioneer and an Explorer...
Alright so, I don't know howww lava is gonna make this more moist
But I'm gonna give it a go
Let's cook you up, I suppose
Alright
I got me some new creatures- God that guy is going to keep complaining 'til the day goes away
Hell yeah!
That kinda worked!
Worked well enough, I got what I need.
So! I don't have water, I don't have pretty much anything.
But what I do have  is KNOWLEDGE.
And knowledge is power in case you didn't know.
So, what I'm gonna do is I've been told
by some people - hey Lester. Come on with me. You ain't bothering me that much
But I've been told by some people, there is titanium down here
which brings me in a nice segway to the comments for this video,
so thank you everybody for leaving so many nice comments on the last one
here is a words from SethBegly
which really reinforced my idea of making a base down here because I think it'd be freaking awsome
Seth said: '' Mark you remember the tiger plant seeds? You should try to put them outside your lava base you're gonna make so you can ward off that Sea Dragon.''
And uhh, that's pretty damn nice because it's ascidering
''Hey look! It's old Mark!''
and then I said:
''YOU DARN SEA DRAGON KID, GET OFF MY PROPERTY!''
and then
Tiger-plant's furious machine gun noises
Like I just imagine that and the way they wrote it out was like, if the Sea Dragon ever came by then
my tiger-plants would just : *Machine gun noises*
And hopefully kill the Sea Dragon which I don't know if it's even possible
but TYSM said that the Sea Dragon CAN be killed
It has hit points which means that it can eventually be killed
Technically when people kill Reaper Leviathans
and what I tried to do on the stream I was very close to doing it but then I gave up before I ahhh-
actully had a chance to,  okay
What di- man that Lester got knocked the shit outta here
Ok, but what happened was uhh a Sea Dragon takes 158 knife swings! To kill it. Which is a lot!
I broke two knives just trying to do that myself but if I would have gotten a few more I may have actually done a dent in it
Which I don't know if it would have been worth it other than just bragging rights
but I could have done that
Oh, also Mr. Sameru said:
''Hey Mark! They're gonna make the Cyclops destructable again which might wanna make you rethink your kamekazi tactics for your Cyclops against the dragon.''
And I say nay to that.
There's only one way I know how to play
And that's by ramming whatever I have in my near vicinity into the closest monster
and by monster I mean literally anything in here is a monster compared to me
and then Pinecone said-uuh: "Mark what if the entire planet is a Sea Dragon swimming in the sea of space?"
And i think you may have... I think you may have puffed a  little to deeply from the-the spliff that is Subnautica
if that made any sense at all
you may have... you may have quaffed... quaff a little too
greedily on the... on the-on the... on the joint to that is Subnautica
so uuhh you're just too high right now sooo ...
Calm down
Wait, no. This is the way I came
Well then what was the other way?
Wait a minute... I'm confused here
So
If this is the way I came, then what's over there?
There wouldn't happen to be two ways into the active lava zone, would there?
'Cuz that'd be super weird
I mean it's kinda like the, uhh,
It's kinda like the lost river with all the
rivers, and horrible chlorine gas that was just
coating the bottom floors
BUT THIS TIME ITS LAVA!!!
MELT YOUR FACE OFF STYLE LAVA!
ALL YOUR SKIN GO GONE, LAVA!
Which I don't know which one's worse,
one melts your skin off with gas,
one melts your skin off with horrible, searing pain.
Actually, they both do that, but-- Whoa, my God.
Wait, there WAS a way down here.
HEY, BEEP BEEP, I'M A JEEP. BEEP BEEP, FUUUCK YOU.
Oh yeah, try, yeah, try. Try, TRY IT.
Did you try it? Did it work? No, fuck off.
What the heeeck?
Where the heck-- ooh, hey, you jolted up outta nowhere.
Where am I now? Am I BACK?!
AM I BACK?
HOW'D I GET HERE? Well, shiiiit.
Well, shiiit.
Alright, well, apparently I got back into the active lava zone.
Don't know how I made my way here.
But NOW this segways into what I wanna do next
because there wasn't anything else down there to do.
Literally, it's just that zone and that building that you can't go into
SO. In respect for that idea,
I'm gonna go back up.
And then starts the preparation phase, because I--
I have a FULL, FULL interest in making sure that that place
down there is my own. WE WILL EITHER cohabitate there
the Sea Dragon and I,
or he will discover that there can be ONLY ONE
MONSTER in this sea, and it crash-landed on a ship
59 episodes ago.
I think I might be, like, a looong time ago, the only way
I knew how to get into the active zone, or the lava zone
in general, was through a weird hole
in the middle of nowhere. There was this weird hole,
right out by the dunes, on the other side of
the mushroom forest.
I don't know where I am now because I apparently hit a wall.
It's okay. I KNOW HOW TO NAVIGATE.
Hey, you guys, BACK OFF. I KNOW WHAT I'M DOING.
Hey, you think-- you wanna drive?? OH, YOU wanna drive?
Oh, okay, go ahead! We'll do Twitch Plays Subnautica
and you guys can control my sub for me.
Don't worry, I'll figure out a way to do it.
I'll just map all the keys to my controller.
It'll be good.
Hope I can still go up. Nope. Can't do that.
Where the hecky-- well this can't be NOTHING!
Can it?
WHERE THE HECK AM I GOIN?
Ah, I see. More left.
I did the opposite of that.
I continued to go right and straight into a blank wall
when I should've been going THAT way.
...Or maybe this is nowhere.
Where the frick am I?
So I did come back. So there were two entrances to that
active lava zone. One, a hole in the ground with a crack
in it, and the other just kind of like a straight-down shot.
OH, hey, dragon.
Alright, I'll be back.
Alright. I'M GOING TO MAKE THE ARDUOUS JOURNEY,
without hitting anything, back to where I need to go.
And YOU, sack of shit you,
YOU. I'm gonna come back for you.
Don't even think about it! I'm outta your league anyway.
You're not ATTRAAACTIVE enough.
Yeah, don't think you're pretty 'cause you're NOT.
NOT AS PRETTY AS ME ANYWAY.
I mean, I admit, the lights are nice.
But you...you need to take it down a notch.
Get that ego in check before I CHECK IT FOR YOU.
ALRIGHT, time to clean off the  cruud.
Actually, you know what, they can  see the light of day!
Maybe they've earned it
Maybe they've earned a ride to the surface
Maybe they'll explode from the pressure difference.
That'll actually happen if you take...
creatures from like the very deepest parts of our oceans
in real life. And if you bring 'em up top
they're used to such crushing pressures,
their bodies are built that way there.
A-and if you don't give them time to adjust  to equilibrium...
Not that they'd be able to survive anyway.
But they will literally EXPLODE
Just because, the pressure is too great.
'Cuz if like
you've ever seen a video of
us going way deep down in a sub. or something
An then they'll put out like
uh, Styrofoam cup, out into the water
It'll be crushed, Instantly, by the water pressure
I mean... that's why all of these things fail
because the water pressure is too high
for the structural integrity of these ships...
to sustain itself.
And THEREFORE, if you were to do the reverse-
okay, so bye have fun back-flipping into next year
Alright, through that. That's cool too.
But if you were to bring them uP
They would POP. And that is NO good.
Gahd, I've been down in the lava zone for so long, I've forgotten what the rest of Subnautica looks like
Oh, I mean of all the zones, PROBABLY the blood kelp zone is probably one of my least explored.
That's guaranteed. 100%. Guaranteed.
It's uh-it's one of the lower end ones
Guehh
Just cuz' I don't wanna be here, it's so creepy.
*CAUTION: Dehydration detected*
Ohhhh, Karen, don't you know,
I'm in the normal ocean now...
I can't be hurt by any means.
...Oh my God, is it DAY?
AAuurrghhh. Is it honestly, DAY?
Am I really free?
Am I actually free?
Could I HONESTLY be FREE?
Free from the Torment!
Free from the shackles of the Lava?
WHAT is this BRIGHT light.
UGGHH
I can't believe it!
EHHH. AAUUGGHH
WOAAHHH. We flew high. OKAY!
Aaand Splaadoosh!
Oh My God! The Sun! I can see it again!
UUUHHHHH! OH MY GOD! IT'S BEEN YEARS!
It's been Flip-dickin' years!
I'm so far away from the ship, I can barely see it!
GOOD GOD! IT's been YEARS!
How many episodes has it been!!??
It's the frikin' sun!
And also. Using the camera at the top is real nice!
BUT, ya know, easy come, easy go...
HEUH, Spladoosh
OH, OH, and of course, I get here just in time for an eclipse!
Well.. actually that's pretty cool! I guess I could see that in the camera...
OHH MY GODD!!!
Actually, that's really pretty! That's really cool.
I mean, I really like the fact that that's possible in this game!
That the whole SUN can just be ECLIPSED  out!
AAWWWHHH. That's awsome! This is AWUSOME
AWUSOME to the MAX
ANYWAAYS, I gotta dive back down... BYe Sun! I'll see ya never, I guess...
But I gotta get back down, because I'm now on the surface again!
AH, the familiar, NOT-sea dragon roars!
Oh, its so good to hear from ya again!
Why, I almost ran into ya, Geez!
HEEEYYYY! SUP! How's it goin? How ya doin?
EEEUUUUNNNGGGGHHHH! Remember me>
Oh, oh, you're lookin'. Ya, I'm a looker alright!
Big, yellow, must be Barry
You know who it is! You know where to find me!
I gotta, eh, drink somethin'.
ALRIGHT! SO, I may be back on the surface and I may be in the midst of
being resinous and whatnot!
AND I know I have a quest, I do. I have a very important quest with which I need to accomplish to the best
of my ability, even though i could die in the process...
I'm very brave, I-I indeed I am...I know I am brave.
But, there is one more thing I need to explore while we're here.
So, what we're looking for is the new biome.
Called the Crag Fields.
Now, the Crag Fields, are located, quite conveniently,
right behind, the Aurora's wreckage.
Right, to the south of the engines if that is south...
If that is south... I believe the Aurora is pointed North.
Can never be too sure unless you build a compass, and I'm not gonna waste resources building that. Why would I?
But down there, is the Crag Fields,
And supposedly, the Crag Fields are some of the most resource-abundant things that you can possible hope for.
Which means that's gonna be good for me for restocking
and getting down into the depths.
But before I even do that, I need to make sure I have all the tools necessary
to deal with an angry neighbour such that as the Sea-Dragon.
Which means I need guns.
Upgrades. Base material. Every other possible thing you could hope for.
I'm going to leav-le-load~
I'm gonna load my cyclops up to the nips.
With every resource I could possibly gather.
And only then-AND ONLY THEN, am I prepared to go back down but,
That's for another day. But we're not done yet.
We got- hello. Are you- I'm in the middle of a very important progress report,
and you're just doing backflips on the surface?
What's wrong with you??
What are you doing??
What the hell are you doing?
*Silence* Okay..
Might I also add that you look much bigger than the other Reefbacks I've ever seen.
No, literally you're like, the biggest Reefback I've ever seen in my Goddamned life.
You're like flip-dickin' hUGE.
Don't look at me like that.
Karen: Caution, mild dehydration detected- Mark: Don't look at me like that. Okay, alright.
Seriously you make Big-Box-Barry look like Petite-Box-Petunia.
Jesus. But anyways, we gotta get down here,
we gotta do some shit, let's do this shit.
We-Oh hey, there you are. I've been lookin' all over for you.
I've got a few bones to pick with you, but maybe you can just carry on your way.
Hey I discovered who-um, literally eats you for breakfast, and the name rhymes with plea-blagon.
Eyy- How you doin' there.
You good? You been okay without me?
Ya scared little baby- ohh, no.
Just 'cause I'm talkin' big inside this shell doesn't mean that I want you anywhere near me so, how 'bout you just- uh, F-Off.
And go away.. thank you.
Oh- if I'm not mistaken that's a crag.
Now, I'm not an expert on what a Crag is- but, if I had to guess-
Ohh- I'd say that these peculiar outcroppings just jutting up from the ground such as this-
It might be a bit of a crag-gy field which means that uhh *Crashing into something*-I'm sorry.
Which means that I'm in the midst of one of the most resource abundant locations in the game and
THAT IS QUITE obviously true, considering I see nothing but titanium every where ya LOOK.
Oh! It's a big'un beauty, but there's alot of bonesharks around here.
So I'm gonna have to take Mr. Fister out.
But first before I do that, I gotta take care of some uninvited guests.
Some people who don't belong here.
hNUGH-YOU KNOW your time was comin' LESTER.
Oh you think you can hide from me Lester? Yeesh- OK.
Lester can you help me hide? (Rlly mark) God, you are red and sWOLLEN with energy.
GET OFF MY GODDAMNED BOAT. Oh no- It's fused permanently.
Could you- AHA! Found your weak spot.
AHA! How'd you even stay here?
How'd you even get AROUND here??
HUH? Oh-Whoooa we got another freeloader.
Can you- uhm, kindly get the fuck away?
How 'bout you don't. The other one got so swollen.
It just exploded the second it tried to eat.
Yea that's right- you go and, and uh,
This is MY territory. You can't stop me from getting what's MINE.
And it's all mine now.
Whoosh. That's alot of shit. OK- so we're in the Crag Field. Which means that we need to go out there and get what's ours..
And there's a whole lot of it just waiting to be got.
Alright, Let's do this!
WHOO- LET'S DO THIS! I guess I can put this Blue Artifact away that might be intelligent
Before I actually go out there and die again and lose all my shit
*sigh* Oh- keep calm poster- you been keeping me calm the entirety of this crazy journey.
Oh, thank you for being there in the dark times and the light. You too guys- don't think I've
Don't think I've forgotten about how you guys have been helpin' me all this way.
I know it hasn't been an easy journey.
Also- I know now that I can actually make Lithium Iron batteries. And I totally forgot about that.
Ah- those are tiger plants. EHUEY-  I'm gonna get you
I'ma get YOU. Oh- I'm gonna get you.
Oh, don't worry I'm gonna get you. Can you even hurt this thing?
I bet I can hurt you. I want your sEEDS.
Try me. Try me. Try me. C'mon try me. Ohups.  Well that didn't work.
Nnh- alright then I'll try ya later. Oh- whoa, hey- whoa-whoa. What are you doing? *scared Mark noises*
*More scared Marok noises* What are you doin', what are you doin', what are you doin'?
HEY! You wanna get ground? Oh you 'bout to get ground! Oh you 'bout to get ground!!
Where'd you go? You tryna escape from your grinding? Huh??
Huh?? Little baby don't wanna get ground! Oh! Oh~no~ it's too late.
Alright. That' all the warning you'll get. Oh, you got me far away from my boat.
Why did you do that? I don't like this!! This seems like a coordinated effort to bone me over!
By bone sharks. Hey. Sack o' tits.
Don't even try it. Oh man! It's a bounty! There's so much titanium here!
This is endless and endless field of titanium!! Like hell to the yea.
Oh man, this is perfect. This is exactly what I needed- If one thing I need, it's unlimited titanium.
And number two: I dunno- whoa. What the fuck?
What is THAT?
What the frick is that?
What is that??
What - it's black!! I mean it's like oily- OH!!
It's a big lithium.That is not what I expected it to be. Wow. OK.
Alright then. I'm down then I-I guess.
Can make more lithium-ion power cells at leas- ah fuck.
ALRIGHT. C'mon! Let's get back in Big-Box-Barry!!
BIG-BOX-BARRY!! WELCOME ME INTO YOUR BOSOM.
Alright so I'm gonna start from the bottom with Eryn_LaneB and then start slappin' in my titanium here. Oh god-that's all that's gonna take.
So I'm gonna get alot of this. A-A whole lot of this. I'm gonna do a bunch of farming between this episode and the next episode.
But I'm in the Crag Field, baby.
Which means that I got a lot of work to do. I gotta gather up literally everything, and then I gotta take this to my other base.
Get some upgrades, make some guns. I don;'t have the patterns I gotta find 'em.
Either way, I've a lot of work left before I hang my Keep Caaalm Kitty poster down there in the lava zone.
But it's gonna happen no matter what. So thank you everybody for watching, let me know how I'm doin' down in the comments below.
But if you wanna be put on a locker again, of which I am going to have,
Let me know down in the comments below.
Write something cool for me to look at. Maybe some info, maybe some encouragement, maybe some funny jokes to make me laugh I'll take what I can get.
So thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always, I will see you in the next video. BUH-BYE.
[Music]